pour une petite sortie dans l'espace ça
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal on a du
nitrogène à l'arrière alors bon vous
l'aurez pas vous pourrez pas vous
laisser mais en tout cas ça c'est module
de la NASA pour pouvoir aller faire un
petit tour alors je vous montre l'exposé
ici là je suis à Las Vegas vous voyez
sur un salon qui s'appelle rimark
organisé par Amazon Cloud à WS et puis
comme on parle de l'espace comment on
parle de mars on nous montre un peu de
matos alors ça c'est un peu daté comme
matériel c'est les années 80 mais ça
c'est quand même très simple à regarder
alors on va pouvoir régler pas mal de
petites choses là je ne sais absolument
rien je ne sais pas je vous montre juste
je partage ce truc que je trouve
complètement dingo et je sais pas si ce
modèle d'ailleurs est déjà parti sur euh
pas sur moi ça me donne en tout cas
parce que personne n'est encore allé sur
mars en tout cas pas d'humain donc voilà
je monte je partage c'est bluffant quand
même c'est hyper impressionnant vous
verriez vous là dedans vous verriez
partir sur Mars si vous pouvez est-ce
que vous verrez même partir sur la lune
si on pouvait c'est dingue dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez